Crews captured the arrest live showing
heavily armed federal agents taking the
suspect into custody Thursday outside
his mother's home south of Boston the
suspect is identified as Massachusetts
Air National Guardsman Jack Tashara he's
accused of leaking hundreds of pages of
classified military documents and CIA
updates including on the war in Ukraine
some revealing how the U.S gathers
Intelligence on both allies and
adversaries Tashira installed fiber
optic cable and that Tech job may have
allowed him to monitor networks through
which classified intelligence flowed the
Pentagon first discovered highly
classified material posted on social
media a week ago though the leak
apparently began late last year when the
documents surfaced in a chat group on
the gaming platform Discord